Mark: Boo!
Mom: Oooh! [Laughs]
Mark: Did that scare you?
Mom: A little bit.
Mark: A little bit? Yeah.
Mark: Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to "My Mom Plays Five Nights at Freddy's."
Mom: Hi everybody, my name is...
Mark: Yeah.
Momiplier: What is it?
Mark: Momiplier.
Momiplier: Mom! Momiplier.
Momiplier: Momiplier.
Mark: Yeah, actually, you could say your real name. I-I'll give you the option.
Please don't make everyone assume that I'm forcing you to call yourself Momiplier. (THE MONSTER)
Momiplier: No, no, no! I, I'm very comfortable.
Mark: Yeah. Okay. So, do you know how to play this game?
Momiplier: I have no idea.
Mark: But you've seen me play it, maybe?
Momiplier: A million times.
Mark: Yeah, okay. So, there is a, uh, walking teddy bear by the name of Fronko Fonbon
Momiplier: [Wheezes]
Mark:  And he is haunting a, uh, uh, uh, a, a, a, uh- Chinese buffet.
Momiplier: [Cackles] Okay!
Mark: You just got hired as a security guard.
Momiplier: Whoopy-Doo!
Mark: [Laughs] Oopy-Doo!
What, y-you're not happy about that?
Momiplier: Hmm, so see.
Mark: Okay. So, it's 12 AM on the first night.
Momiplier: Ok.
Mark: So you need to listen very closely, he's gonna give you instructions.
Mark: And you need to listen very closely.
Phone Guy: ... but there's really nothing to worry about. Uh-
Momiplier: I'm not worried.
Phone Guy: ...the animatronic characters here...
Mark: Yeah, why would you be?
Phone Guy:. ...do get a bit quirky at night...
Phone Guy: Alright, good night.
Mark: Alright. So now, you're in charge. So what do you gather from what he was saying to you?
Momiplier: Uhh...
Mark: What do you think?
Momiplier: They're gonna try to... Make... Something I don't wanna be? Or scare me?
Mark: Yeah, something like that. They're gonna make you something you don't wanna be. That's-
Momiplier: Yeah, yeah.
Mark: That's pretty much the long and the short of exactly what's going here.
Momiplier: Yeah. I'm looking at them...
Mark: Yes.
Momiplier: But nobody's there.
Mark: Do you see where you are?
Momiplier: I'm at-
Mark: The bottom
Momiplier: Eh? Oh, I'm here!
Mark: Yeah!
Momiplier: Okay.
Mark: There.
Momiplier: Oohh! Camera 4B.
Momiplier: What am I-
Mark: Yeah, you almost had 'em.
Momiplier: Had what?
Mark: Close, yeah.
Momiplier: What about here?
Mark: Yeah. Go!
Momiplier: Hmm.
Mark: Nothing there.
Momiplier: Where?
Mark: Suspicious.
Momiplier: What am I looking for?
Mark: You're looking for them!
Momiplier: Who?
Mark: The animatronics!
Momiplier: They're alive?
Mark: No, they're- Ah, it's questionable whether they're alive or not.
Momiplier: Do- What do I hear?
Mark: Is something different there?
Momiplier: Yeah, dum-dum-dum? I heard that. I hear.
Mark: Ahh.
Momiplier: Oh.
Mark: Well, that's Freddy, he likes to sing.
Momiplier: Oh...
Mark: And also, there's another. There's three animatronics in total.
Mark: There's Fronko, Chonko, and Bonko.
Momiplier: [Wheezes] Chonko...
GOD DAMN IT MARK YOU FORGOT FONKO THE FOX I MEAN SERIOUSLY WHAT IF FONKO CAME UP TO MOMIPLIER AND YOU NEVER SAID ANYTHING ABOUT FONKO HUH? HOW WOULD YOU FEEL?
Mark: You gotta make sure you watch out for Bonko, he's a tricky one.
Momiplier: [Chuckles] Okay! Okay.
Momiplier: Oh! I'm a little scared.
Momiplier: Oh, It's 4 AM! Do I have to go until 6 AM, right?
Mark: Yeah, yeah. 6 AM, you got it.
Momiplier: Oh, my gosh!
Mark: No...
Momiplier: I suddenly am very, very scared!
Mark: I know, right?
Momiplier: Ohh...
Mark: Yeah, Bonko is gonna sneak up behind you.
Momiplier: [Laughs]
Mark: Watch out for Chonko!
Momiplier: [Laughs] Oh no!
Mark: Fronko's the worst of them all.
Momiplier: Come on! Where are you?
Mark: Yeah, where are they? You've actually, I will, I will- Well, you wanna know something spooky?
Momiplier: What?
Mark: You've looked at two of them.
Momiplier: Oh, where?
Mark: I know, right?
Momiplier: Wh-
Mark: You've seen two of them.
Momiplier: I've seen tw- right here! What is that?
Mark: Yeah- No, that's a poster
Momiplier: Where?
Mark: What about 1B? What about 1B?
Momiplier: Okay... This one?
Mark: Yaaaaaaay, you found him!
Momiplier: Freddy! Freddy!
Mark: [Laughs] Not quite!
Momiplier: Oh, it's not Freddy?
Mark: That might be Freddy - actually I think that's Freddy.
Momiplier: Yeah!
Mark: If I look closely... Yeah, Freddy.
Momiplier: So what is it doing here?
Mark: Umm...
Momiplier: Why is he here!?
Mark: He's just relaxing, you know...
Momiplier: He's okay?
Mark: He's having a good time!
Momiplier: Was he here before?
Mark: Oh, I don't know...
Momiplier: I don't remember...
Momiplier: So what- where do- where should I go?
Mark: Oh, you know, around...
Momiplier: Just look around?
Mark: Yeah.
Mark: Who's that? Is that-
Momiplier: Freddy?
Mark: They can't all be Freddy.
Momiplier: [Clicks Tongue] I don't know... They look all alike to me.
Mark: [Snickers]
Momiplier: They look allllll alike!
Momiplier: I have n-
Mark: Ohh!
Momiplier: Oh! What is that.
Momiplier: Let's... Eat?
Momiplier: That's the one, what is this?
Mark: What do you think, what's that one's name?
Momiplier: Chica!
Mark: Chonko!
Momiplier: Chonko...
Mark: Chonko.
Momiplier: Chonko.
Mark: Yeah. Chonko.
Momiplier: Okay.
Mark: You want to save your power, is the thing.
Momiplier: Power?
Mark: Yeah-
Momiplier: I have 19%
Momiplier: 18... Percent...
[Victory bells]
Momiplier: [Gasps]
Mark: You did it!
Momiplier: Ooooooooooooooh!
Momiplier: [Laughs of joy]
Mark: You won!
Mark: You won the game!
Momiplier: [Screams of victory]
Mark: You're the best! You did it!
Mark: Congratulations!
Momiplier: Ooh!
Mark: Oh, here's the second night.
Momiplier: Okay...
Mark: There's another night.
Momiplier: Alright!
Mark: It's gonna get even harder now.
Momiplier: Naaah.
Mark: Naaah?
Momiplier: Piece of pie!
Mark: Piece of pie?
Momiplier: Uh-huh.
Mark: Okay.
Phone Guy: The character in there seems unique in that he becomes more active if the cameras...
Mark: Uh oh.
Phone Guy: ...remain off for long periods of time.
Mark: Uhh...
Phone Guy: I guess he doesn't like being watched.
Phone Guy: I don't know. Anyway, I'm sure you have everything under control! Uh...
Mark: Oh, no...
Phone Guy: Talk to you soon!
Bonnie: [Groan]
Mark: Piece of candy...
Momiplier: I hear something...
Mark: You hear something?
Momiplier: I better watch carefully, right?
Mark: [Mumbles spookily] You better watch carefully...
Momiplier: Nobody is he-ere!
Mark: Look at that...
Momiplier: [Tauntingly] I'm watching youuuu!
Mark: They're all looking at you.
Mark: Oh, they're all looking at you.
Momiplier: Me too! I'm looking at you too!
Mark: [Silent laugh]
Momiplier: Ah!
Mark: They're all looking at you!
Bonnie: [Groan]
Momiplier: Whoooo...
Mark: I know.
Momiplier: ...ooh... Whoop!
Momiplier: I'm watching you- OOH!
Bonnie: [SCREECH]
Momiplier: [Screams, turning into laughter]
Mark: [Laughs]
Momiplier: [Laughing] Noo!
Mark: [Laughing]
Momiplier: [Laughing] Oh my god!
Mark: [Laughing too]
Mark: Yeah... Uhh, yeah.
Momiplier: [Still laughing]
Mark: I knew you were dead a while ago... (r00d)
Momiplier: [Laughing] What happened?
Mark: Yeah...
Mark: You, you, you remember how when you tried to push the light on the left side, it wouldn't work?
Momiplier: Yeah.
Mark: That's-
Momiplier: Oh, it's there!
Mark: Yeah.
Momiplier: Oohh!
Mark: That meant it was too late!
Momiplier: Mmmm...
Mark: Okay, hit continue.
Momiplier: Bubble! Let's watch carefully...
Mark: You've got to watch care-
Momiplier: So they don't kill us, okay?
Mark: Cus' they move! You've gotta-
Momiplier: Okay.
Mark: You've got to be mindful of these!
Momiplier: I am, I am! Come here.
Momiplier: It's one, right?
Momiplier: Where are you?
Momiplier: I'm watching you!
Mark: No, no. They're all on stage right now.
Mark: Oh, they're looking at you again.
Momiplier: Oooooh, that looks-
Mark: See the way they're looking at you?
Momiplier: Oooh! That looks...
Mark: Spooky...
Momiplier: Ooh, spooky.
Mark: That's not good...
Momiplier: Okay... Nobody's here.
Mark: Nobody there.
Momiplier: Three...
Foxy: Dum dum dum...
Momiplier: Oh! I hear "Dum dum dum!"
Momiplier: How about six!
Mark: Could be... But you kn-
Momiplier: Kitchen!
Mark: Do you hear pots and pans?
Momiplier: I hear- I hear- I hear- I hear pots and pans!
Mark: Chica's in the kitchen.
Momiplier: Why? Oh, she wants to eat something!
Momiplier: She's hungry.
Mark: Yeah... Very good. [Laughs]
Momiplier: Oooh, oooh I hear!
Mark: Oh!
Momiplier: Clank and clanking!
Mark: Ohhhh, she likes to eat!
Momiplier: Somebody looking for pizza leftover!
Mark: Uh huh... [Laughs]
Momiplier: [Laughs]
Momiplier: [Laughing]
Mark: So maybe... Check your left side of the hall.
Momiplier: [Nervous Laughter]
Momiplier: Okay... [Terrified]
Mark: 3, 2...
Momiplier: [Sounds of terror] Don't- don't- don't come sneak on me!
Momiplier: Ah! Ah!
Mark: Don't sneak on her!
Mark: Check 2B.
Momiplier: 2B!
Mark: Oh...
Momiplier: Uhm...
Momiplier: Ohh!
Mark: That poster don't look so good...
Momiplier: Yeah, what happened?
Mark: I don't know.
Momiplier: Oh, okay.
Mark: Go check your door lights,
Momiplier: Oohh!
Mark: To make sure there's no one standing there.
Momiplier: Oh, no one.
Mark: No one there.
Momiplier: How about here?
Mark: Careful.
Momiplier: Go here?
Mark: Yeah. Check that one.
Momiplier: Ooh.
Mark: You've gotta remember: if you don't know where they are on the camera,
Mom: Ohh...
Mark: You might wanna... You might wanna check...
Mark: Oh, I see her. She's in the top right.
Momiplier: I see! Let's eat!
Mark: Yeah!
Momiplier: Oohh!
Mark: Yeeah!
Momiplier: Oh, now she is near the bathroom after eat- Ooh.
Momiplier: What should I do?
Mark: [Laughs]
Momiplier: Oohh...
Mark: Why would she be near the bathroom after eating?
Momiplier: Because! She ate too much!
Momiplier: Had to go p... Potty!
Mark: Yeah.
Momiplier: I'm here! I'm here! I'm good.
Mark: You're good, you're good.
Momiplier: Oh, Ooh! Ooh! Oooh!
Mark: Ooh, she's coming down the hall!
Momiplier: Hey!
Mark: Yeah, she's coming!
Momiplier: Aren't you full enough?
Mark: Nope.
Momiplier: Ah! Come on!
Mark: She needs one more meal!
Momiplier: I thought you had already! Bunch of leftover pizza!
Mark: [Laughs]
Momiplier: [Laughs of terror] Come on!
Momiplier: Do I look like a pizza?
Momiplier: [Whimpers]
Momiplier: I'm watching you!
Mark: You're watching.
Momiplier: Oh my goodness! What should I do?
Bubble: [Whining]
Mark: She's not that close yet, but when she gets to 4B-
Bonnie: [Shrieks]
Momiplier: [Screams, wheezes]
Momiplier: [Laughing]
Mark: You weren't watching! You weren't watching!
Mark: You were so focused on Chica you forgot the left side!
Momiplier: Where in the world d- What's his name?
Momiplier: Freddy?
Mark: Freddy? Freddy?
Momiplier: He sneak on me!
Mark: I know! Sneaky Freddy!
Momiplier: I was watching the other one!
Mark: I know!
Momiplier: [Laughing]
Mark: Freddy sneak on you!
Momiplier: Oohh...
Mark: Freddy likes to sneak on you.
Momiplier: Wow Freddy, you are-
Mark: Give it one more try!
Momiplier: You are... Sneaky bastard!
Mark: One- Oh no, not new game!
Momiplier: Oh, continue? Oh my god.
Mark: Yeah.
Mark: Just one more try!
Mark: That Freddy!
Momiplier: Whew! I'm too old for this!
Mark: You get one more try, and then we'll give your poor, old heart a rest.
Momiplier: [Laughing from suffering] Oh gee...
Momiplier: [Laughing]
Mark: You're good! You're doing great.
Mark: Just keep observing!
Momiplier: Oh, okay, now.
Mark: Stay focused, stay true!
Momiplier: I'm here!
Mark: Remember:
Mark: Chonko likes the right side,
Momiplier: Okay.
Mark: Freddy likes the left side!
Momiplier: Ahhh, okay, bathroom... Nobody here.
Mark: Yeah...
Momiplier: Kitchen, nobody here.
Mark: I know...
Mark: Okay.
Momiplier: Party time! Nobody here!
Momiplier: Oh!
Momiplier: I'm watching you guys...
Momiplier: Don't you dare...
Momiplier: Don't you dare come near me like that!
Momiplier: [Sounds of fear]
Mark: They're gonna sneak on you...
Momiplier: Nooooo, no no no!
Mark: [Laughs]
Momiplier: You better not! You better not!
Momiplier: I'm watching you!
Momiplier: I'm watching you...
Momiplier: Oh!
Momiplier: Okay, it's not here.
Mark: It seems good.
Mark: Alright, I think- I think they're gone...
Momiplier: Are they gone?
Mark: I think Freddy has left the stage.
Momiplier: Well, maybe Freddy is scared of me too.
Mark: I'm scared of you, so that would make sense.
Momiplier: [Laughs]
Momiplier: Ooh, ooh, oooh!
Mark: Oooooooh... Oooooh.
Mark: Hello!
Momiplier: [Laughs]
Mark: [Laughs]
Mark: That's good, that's good! I like it! I think that'll work!
Momiplier: [Laughs] It works!
Momiplier: Not only- What did you do?
Mark: Oh, the one fing-[Laughs] The middle finger at Freddy's!
Momiplier: I do it like this! [Laughs]
Momiplier: It works! [Laughs]
Mark: Ooh, ooh, gonna get ya!
Mark: Alright, so you might wanna, you might wanna look out.
Momiplier: Yeah.
Mark: 'Cause, uhh...
Mark: I think they're coming for you.
Momiplier: Oooh. Ooh.
Mark: Check those lights. Check those lights.
Momiplier: Uh oh...
Mark: Yeah.
Momiplier: Okay, I'm gonna go here...
Mark: Okay, good.
Momiplier: Boo! [Laughs]
Mark: mmmBOOP!
Momiplier: [Laughs]
Mark: He's not there, amazingly!
Momiplier: Boo! [Laughs]
Mark: [Laughs]
Momiplier: I'm gonna scare them before they scare me!
Mark: That's a good strategy!
Momiplier: That's my strategy.
Mark: Good strategy. I like it.
Momiplier: I've watched your video a million times, no.
Mark: Oh, I think that's going to work-Uh oh.
Momiplier: Ooh.
Mark: Here comes Chonko.
Momiplier: Ooh. Hello! Hello! Hello!
Momiplier: Ehh!
Momiplier: Hello!
Mark: [Laughs]
Mark: Remember the left side.
Momiplier: Hey light! [Laughs]
Mark: [Laughs]
Mark: Right...
Momiplier: Boo! [Laughs] I'm gonna scare them!
Mark: You're gonna!
Momiplier: Oh my goodness!
Mark: You're getting-
Momiplier: Freddy!
Mark: Check those lights!
Momiplier: [Sounds of stress]
Mark: Alright.
Momiplier: Come on... Boo!
Mark: Check that left side again, I think they might've gotten close.
Momiplier: Are you sure?
Mark: Yeah.
Momiplier: Boo! [Laughs] That is not-
Mark: Okay, check 2B.
Momiplier: I was going to.
Mark: Okay, what about 4B.
Momiplier: I was going to!
Mark: Okay, you know how to play this game!
Momiplier: I'm expert!
Mark: 'Axpert'!
Momiplier: Ooh. Who are you?
Mark: Who are you?
Momiplier: What're you doing there?
Momiplier: Who are you?
Mark: Who is that?
Momiplier: What are you doing there?
Mark: I don't know. I've always wondered that, why does he go into the supply closet?
Momiplier: I don't know.
Mark: Huh, what a weirdo.
Momiplier: Hmm...
Momiplier: Boo! Oh, nobody here!
Momiplier: What's going on?
Mark: I don't know!
Momiplier: Okay... See? See? Momiplier!
Momiplier: You're scary, right?
Mark: Yeah, oh yeah! I know.
Momiplier: Yeah. Boo! [Laughs]
Mark: Nothing yet!
Momiplier: 2B! Oooh!
Mark: Oh!
Momiplier: Hello!
Mark: Just keep an eye on him.
Momiplier: How?
Mark: Just watch him, right here.
Momiplier: Just watch him?
Mark: If he moves from there- Check your light! Now. Check your light.
Momiplier: Oooh! Light! Light, light!
Momiplier: Boom! [Screams while laughing]
Mark: Hit the door! Hit the door! Hit the door!
Mark: There you go. You got it! You're getting it! You're getting it!
Momiplier: [Laughing]
Mark: Okay, so now don't open the door, but check the light one more time.
Momiplier: Okay. [Sounds of fear]
Mark: Don't open the door.
Mark: Okay, he's still there. You see that shadow? The shadow? Yeah, he's still there.
Momiplier: Ohh, you there. Okay, what should I do?
Mark: You should, uh, just wait until he leaves.
Mark: Alright. Check the light again, he might be gone.
Momiplier: [Sounds of complete terror] Oh, I hope so!
Momiplier: [Terrified] Boo...
Mark: See? Yeah, he's gone.
Momiplier: [Sigh of relief]
Mark: Okay. Now you can open the door.
Momiplier: [Sigh]
Mark: Now you can open the door. Yeah.
Momiplier: Okay.
Mark: You've got this!
Momiplier: Can I close now?
Mark: Yeah, turn off the light- no don't close!
Momiplier: Oh, don't close it?
Mark: Yeah, you're running low on power.
Momiplier: Oh shoot.
Mark: That's okay.
Momiplier: 25% of power!
Mark: Yeah. You're at 3 AM, you've got 25%.
Mark: That's not the best. That's not- that's not good. (You just said that was okay, don't lie to your mother)
Momiplier: Oh my goodness, what am I going to do?
Mark: I don't know...
Momiplier: I just want to hide somewhere...
Mark: Check your lights.
Momiplier: Here?
Mark: Yeah.
Momiplier: [Gasps]
Mark: Door!
Mark: Door! Hit the door! [Laughs]
Momiplier: Do it! Close! [Laughs]
Momiplier: At least he just was staring at me, he's not coming near me.
Mark: Yeah! Not killing!
Momiplier: Okay.
Mark: What about the other side? Did you check the other light?
Momiplier: No I haven't.
Mark: You didn't, did you?
Momiplier: Don't you dare... Light!
Mark: Close the door, close the door!
Momiplier: [Screams]
Mark: [Laughs] Turn off the light!
Momiplier: [Nervous laughter] Light off!
Momiplier: Oooh!
Mark: Yeah... That's a problem.
Momiplier: That's Chica in there!
Mark: Yeaaah! That's Chica!
Momiplier: What should I do?
Mark: Nothing you can do!
Momiplier: Heeeeey... How are you?
Mark: Hiiii... [Laughs]
Momiplier: Look, I'm a Momiplier, go away!
Mark: [Laughs]
Momiplier: [Laughs]
Mark: That does give you special authority in these games, you know? Yeah.
Momiplier: [Nervous laughter] Go away!
Mark: As- As a- Since I'm the king of Five Nights at Freddy's...
Momiplier: I'm a queen!
Mark: Oh, you just ran out of power.
Momiplier: Oooh no, I'm dead!
Mark: No, move your camera over to the left side.
Momiplier: [Nervous croak]
Mark: Here, someone's very upset because
Mark: you've been calling Bonnie "Freddy" this whole time.
Momiplier: Oh, gee! [Laughs]
Mark: So someone is mad at you. The REAL Freddy is mad at you.
[Freddy's music]
Momiplier: [Laughing nervously]
Mark: He wants to sing you a song.
Momiplier: [Laughing nervously] Ooh, I don't like this!
Momiplier: [Sounds of terror]
Momiplier: [Terrified] Okay... Okay...
[Music stops]
Mark: Watch out.
Momiplier: What?
Momiplier: What am I looking aAAH! [Screams and laughs]
Markiplier: [Laughs]
Mark: You did it! You died!
Momiplier: [Laughing] I died!
Mark: Here you go, here's Bubble.
Momiplier: [Laughing] Oh, Bubble!
Mark: Bubble will calm you down!
Mark: Well, you didn't do it!
Momiplier: Oh Bubble, I need Bubble-
Mark: You uh, you didn't survive, but you did good!
Mark: You were catching on very quickly, I was surprised!
Momiplier: Hey, I watched a million times of a video!
Momiplier: I should know by now! [Laughs]
Mark: You were doing pretty good!
Momiplier: I should know by now!
Mark: I've got to admit, you were doing pretty good.
Momiplier: Bubble! I need take a medication!
Momiplier: Oh my goodness!
Mark: Oh, wait, you've got to say goodbye!
Mark: We haven't said goodbye yet!
Momiplier: Oh! [Laughing]
Momiplier: I thought that we were still playing-
Momiplier: Oh well!
Mark: Alright, so thank you everybody so much for watching, this has been "My Mom Plays Five Nights at Freddy's."
Momiplier: I've been watching millions of times, but first time I've ever played!
Mark: Yeah. So even though she was naming everything absolutely wrong!
Momiplier: I'm bad at names.
Mark: You were doing pretty good! You were okay! You were alright! You were doing pretty good!
Mark: I'm proud of you. I'm proud of you, you did okay.
Mark: So thank you everybody so much for watching, and thank you Mom for joining me. Any last words of wisdom?
Momiplier: Uhhh... Have fun! Happy new year!
Mark: Have fun! Happy new year! Alright.
Mark: Hey, and thank you again, and as always... We'll see you in the next video. Buh-bye!
Momiplier: Byeeee!